[Music]
we haven't heard about Kevin's face in a
while right oh he got canceled remember
is he back
he was meeting some boys and [ __ ] pretty
much yeah he posted this ten minute
video I liked his acting do we forgive
him that was that he's gonna be me
forever cancer the level of what he did
is it's hard to come back it's not even
like what he did after he did it you
know cuz he was like after he committed
the me to stuff he was just like oh it's
because I'm gay guys and then a whole
gay community it was like whoa whoa whoa
don't put that on us that's your own so
you know who we forgave though which is
pretty crazy are Kelly I was on Pandora
everyone took off his song and then our
Kelly started coming back oh [ __ ] that's
crazy somehow as musics being licensed
again I don't know if he's forgiven but
he's not forgiven he's my canvas paste
post let me give Maya a scar you still
watch that's true yeah but he's not
getting new roles yeah
not from acting you probably got like
investments or whatever residuals such a
good actor so back in 2017 fall 2017 is
when all these allegations came out and
he did that long huh yeah he started
comparing how him losing his whole
career and stuff is is similar to how a
lot of people are feeling because of the
coronavirus layoffs oh no no that's
quite the same brought upon yourself
what is it unfair did some rape ins
do it now you guys know how I feel
that's why I'm like why did you guys ask
for actors and entertainers to be your
goddamn role models yeah [ __ ] crazy
eccentric now we can't operate in the
normal world I mean some of them can
like okay yeah no reason Gianna Reeves
is pretty dope I heard that he but he
stays often ever the nicest guy ever
yeah and even he got blacklisted from
Hollywood five ten years why not from
the public from Hollywood why cuz he
wouldn't join Scientology FL which
he turned down or something but you got
blacklisted you have to meet John wick
himself look at how well he did because
he to use it
[ __ ] called him yeah I only say that
because we're not working with them yet
found the clip here we go
move your heads as much as you can then
do not move your heads what I don't
often like to tell people that I can
relate to their situation because I
think it undermines the experience that
they may be having which is their own
unique and very personal experience but
in this instance I feel as though I can
relate to what it feels like to have
your world sudden stop and so I do have
empathy for what it feels like to
suddenly be told that you can't go back
to work or that you might lose your job
and when my career came to a grinding
screeching halt when I was faced with
the uncertainty that I might never be
hired as an actor again I asked myself a
question I'd never asked myself before
which is if I can't act
Who am I I mean I don't have a lead
myself through my work I'd only define
myself through my work that's who I was
but if that wasn't going to be a
possibility anymore then Who am I and
when all I love rapists is just me and I
know it might be hard to hear right now
but it's at these kinds of moments that
we have the chance to remember that the
most important thing in life is our
health our physical health but also our
mental health the health of our family
of our children or our parents that were
still lucky enough to have with us and
right now we have this opportunity to
just stop and reflect on our lives and
maybe even learn a little bit more about
ourselves and I'm still in my process
but this is a process that has allowed
me to ask other questions I'd never
asked have conversations I'd never had
delve into issues I'd long avoided like
what face truths I'd kept hidden and
confront traumas I
always denied so therapy [ __ ] bigger the
wrong kind to yourself might be the
hardest place to start it certainly was
for me I thought I was gonna ask like
why the chip bags never forget filled to
the top it's not like he's like this is
like an audition tape for a role almost
yeah sounds like he's acting right it
looks like he's acting he's still like
he's doing a pretty inspirational rapist
though marry he just go hey guys I
[ __ ] up I'm so sorry I will never rape
again please give me just one role I'll
make a movie for free right now
I know Netflix are not Hollywood put up
just shut down no but just give me a
couple of cameras and I'll make
something for you I even do a YouTube
video yeah just be real with it you know
I don't think you'll ever play another
convincing role ever again if you did
that like it's their reputation all
you've gotta carry himself a certain way
like a rapist yeah like what if I play a
role of that yeah not bad I would get it
if that was like an athlete that broke
his leg and he could never play football
again and in the huge time relate to the
people like oh my goodness it yeah it's
uh it's something that could have been
prevented or is just something that
happened to them the way that he's
putting it no one likes it because it's
like he's not taking responsibility yeah
that's the problem and that's the same
problem when it first happened but he
didn't take responsibility doing it
again we're gonna learn anything around
the whole thing he's learning more about
himself but still not the fact that he's
the one that [ __ ] up what if he stars
in his own biopic Miri plays the same
rapist seems so maybe we can understand
where he's coming from that's pretty
good but I mean if I invite going
through those scenes it's it's kind of
like his retribution yeah and then it's
like I'm on Scorsese style where there's
a voiceover so you see him like coming
up on these like hot young boys and you
hear his thought ever since I was a
little boy I wanted to be a rapist
like Shia LaBeouf is anywhere near that
but like that's kind of what Shia did
with honey boy sewed like a glimpse into
his childhood how abusive his dad was he
actually played his dad in it [ __ ]
this is kind of like a therapeutic
moment like was stealing friends from
him technically do this movie it's such
a beautiful so when you say cam and
space he should play himself as the
rapist that's not a bad you mean he
needs to play the rabies oh you play the
victim he makes his own cameo yeah I
don't know but I like I like k-pax man
when he was a alien that was my [ __ ]
dude never seen well he was a homeless
guy or a crazy guy that got sent to the
asylum and people wasn't sure if he was
actually it's k-pax k-pax that's the
name of the movie which was the other
one that he thought like he had an input
implant and blubber flubber no he had an
implant in his arm he was crazy though
baby [ __ ] was it that movie I don't
remember it was oohs I was a kid but
that was like one of my favorite Kevin
Spacey movies because at the end of it
I'm just like oh because he disappeared
from the silo so he was telling everyone
yeah I'm gone on this day and then
everyone swore that he teleported back
to his home planet but he escaped yeah I
don't know but um he's he's an amazing
actor that's why I always tell people
like alright there's one thing to say
about a human in and what they produce
in terms of skill right and you know
sometimes people like put them on a
pedestal make them a god and or like
just because someone's skills good
doesn't mean that their character is you
just hope that their character is good
because you admire their abilities but
there's a lot of people like r.kelly who
are amazing [ __ ] talented and crazy
and and they've made some great memories
for us while they were touching young
women and keeping them as sex slaves
well you know like I think there's a lot
of things like that in this world where
there's always some type of hidden
secret to humans there's always some
kind of evil tool or so we're all darker
than we actually sort ray
something going on that's hidden but I
don't know I don't know if there's an
actual human being that's pure like
Jesus hmm I don't know if that exists
yeah
not saying that this forgives mr. k-pax
are [ __ ] a mr. president house of
cards was [ __ ] sick true but I don't
know you're still a rapist yeah yeah I
think the public opinion is if if he
can't serve any kind of punishment
through another system then we can
inflict it on um ourselves which is
blacklisting him not having not giving
him any more like Fame or anything like
that
can we though can we Israel way to make
him receive punishment right that we
then we're like that's cool
we like that kind of planet for his sins
yeah but then also go now can yak again
like I should turn a comedy but the
problem is that apparently it's from
this video it seems like his purpose is
to act then but if you give him his
purpose then he's perfectly contented
huh yeah he's trying to punish men he's
taking that away they separate me from
what I did for my acting let me ask you
what were you saying I didn't feel like
it was kind of going like like all like
I I'm trying to be an act that's all I'm
here for but what if let's say Friday
night we can do spank night right so
this Friday night thank ya well I'm just
creating a Redemption tour for good old
Kevin Spacey here right so it's spank
night right we go to West Hollywood you
could spank Kevin Spacey he'll be like
in a ball gag with some assless chaps
and [ __ ] you get a paddle and anybody
who wants to spank um
you could spank him and take a picture
then he's doing a community service
right and then he does stand-up comedy
he does he does a whole tour shyness
perfect that's yeah yeah when you went
through his [ __ ] yet to talk [ __ ] yeah
you could just say whatever you want to
know yeah yeah it's like a Redemption
tour yeah maybe people will kind of like
ease into it but right now he's too
proud I think he's - yes yeah I know how
you you [ __ ] people feel with the
quarantine when things out of your
nature you you without your control it
just happened to you like me you know
it's true [ __ ] you [ __ ] did that to
yourself you imagine
being him like he's watching the news
and he's like you know what these people
need a little bit of Kevin Spacey you
know like they need me my people need me
I do see him popping up in all these
movies like these old movies
American Beauty was that Netflix not
they just got released on Netflix yeah I
just see a popping up here now the time
is now yeah seeing the American Beauty
though I'm like you're such a [ __ ]
creep yeah it makes the movie better now
actually I separate the artist from what
they do though same here
cuz I can't help but like make that
character like be him it is painted yeah
it's painted exactly like I just see him
as doing that to the victims who like
came out and said like you forced me to
grab his Janet or whatever the [ __ ] like
things like that where I'm like in
American Beauty he was such a [ __ ]
perv yeah although that's not true
acting because he likes guys right
American Beauty have to force them stuff
like a girl that's like what an evil man
knows how to be a stand-up human being
in a movie I'm like wow that must have
taken a lot of work to be a good as we
all know what a [ __ ] bag you are yeah
[Music]